nous Jean Messia s'estime victime d'un
acharnement il lance une cagnotte pour
lui venir en aide j'ai besoin de vous
pour continuer puisque l'arcom a décidé
de décompter son temps d'antenne et donc
il peut pas aller comme il veut dans
faire toutes les télés puisque son temps
est décompté donc forcément moins de
télé moins de sous moins de travail
moins de moins de d'exposition donc
forcément cagnotte et donc on va parler
de la cagnotte dans un instant la
question pour Jean mess est-ce qu'on
peut me la mettre derrière moi ou je me
la fous dans le
cucu si par que vous avez des
comprenez-vous la suspension de Jean
Messia comprenez-vous la suspension de
Jean Messia merci comprenez-vous la
suspension de Jean Messia non non non
non non non je ne comprends pas que
l'arcom qui est censé être un organisme
sérieux et impartial inflige des
sanctions à la tête du client c'est
complètement gratuit la règle est simple
c'est quand vous êtes encarté au
responsable politique ù votre temps est
décomté or Jean Messia n'est ni encarté
ni responsable politique voilà en ce qui
concerne la cagnote je la trouve
totalement légitime Jean Messia vit de
ses interventions sur les plateaux donc
il a pas se retrouver au chômage sans
aucune exposition
rien faire du tout donc tant mieux sil a
68000 € bravo tu vas t'en mettre plein
les fouilles mon
SAL alors moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est tout simplement une première
j'aimerais bien savoir quel est
l'argument de de l'arcom mais à ma
connaissance c'est une première et alors
dans le cadre de l'enquête qu'on est en
train de faire dans le cadre de
l'enquête qu'on est en train de faire
sur france télé moi j'ai posé la
question à l'arcom de personnes qui sont
pas encarté et qui sont quand même
comptabilisé comment est-ce qu'ils font
il soutiennent dans cette réponse que ça
n'est jamais le cas c'est-à-dire que
soit on est encarté et on est considéré
comme étant comme défendant les couleurs
politiques de la franceç insoumis ou des
républicains mais si on n'est pas
encarté on peut pas être comptabilisé
comme tel donc je une petite précision
par rapport à ça c'est que on peut
considérer que les gens sont apparentés
mais alors là si c'est ça c'est mais
est-ce que vous avez déjà été encarté
j'ai j'ai oui que vous avez fait partie
d'un bureau politique vous déjà fait
partie d'un bureau politique il y a 5 ou
6 ans an voil alors là ce ça peut t
l'argumenu ben non pourquoi parce que je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que vous
avez des tas d'autres personnes qui ont
déjà eu des engagements politiques à
gauche à l'extrême gauche qui les exerce
plus quand je suis parti alors je vais
vous raconter l'histoire quand je suis
parti de mon dernier engagement
politique col en avril non c'est un peu
plus intéressant ah c'était Chambé moi
j'adorais tuas vu l'histoire du
colibbrid c'est Colen royale non ah
m'intéresse pas e mais oh C là là allez
vas-y en avril juste
en avril 2022 je quitte définitivement
la politique active j'envoie un courrien
en recommandé à l'arcom pour lui
signifier que j'arrête tout engagement
politique tout toute tentative toute
candidature à une élection et cetera
j'annonce ça publiquement des dépêches à
FP et cetera c'est annoncé au vu aus de
tous pendant presque 2 ans j'exerce donc
l'activité de consultant médiia sans que
l'arcom n'y voit quoi que ce soit ou
quoi que ce soit jamais l'arcom n'a dit
n'a envoyé un courrier ni à moi ni
encore moins ass news pour dire attendez
qu'est-ce qu'il raconte ce type doit
être rien donc il y a une règle
administrative qui ne dit mot qu' sent
comment se fait-il qu'un beau matin une
sombre réunion dans un sombre bureau
d'une sombre tour il y a une tête gr une
tête grisâre qui prend une décision à
l'emportepèces en étiquetant comme ça de
manière intempestive arbitraire et
pérempptoire des gens qui n'ont qui ont
eux-mêmes choisi de pas de de pas avoir
d'étiquette politique c'est surtout une
forme de discrimination je vous confirme
que c'est la première fois que l'arcom
prend une décision pareil sans
justification y a moun qui est d'accord
avec s'ils le font pour vous il faut
qu'il le fasse pour tout le monde
exaelez Moon non mais c'est serès bien
pas mal ouais ça fait 15 fois qu'on 15
fois qu'on l' fait pas grave allez-y non
moi en réalité je c'est pas que je m'en
fiche un peu c'est juste que je trouve
que votre votre cagnote elle est quand
même très très ridicule dans le sens où
je trouve ça très culoté de votre part
je pense que vous gagnez par vous là non
non je parle de vous et je j'estimee
qu'en fait vous avez pas besoin de faire
une cannotte je trouve que c'est
vraiment gros t que sais bah je trouve
ça mais attends mais juste déjà vous
passez votre temps à à dire tous les
grands diplômes que vous avez si
vraiment vous avez tout plein grands
diplômes je comprends pas pourquoi vous
allez pas travailler pour gagner de
l'argent plutôt que de faire une
cagnotte que de faire une cagnotte pour
que les gens vous êtes en train
deexliquer que vous vous travaillez pas
en fait bah si je travaille vous
travaillez pas si vous si vous
considérez que le fait d'être à la télé
et de faire les analyses des analyses et
des éditorix c'est pas
vous travaille pas alors allez
travailler fait travaille déjà ici je
travaille à côté j'estime aussi que vous
il y a un moment où quand vous dites
aussi beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles
je suis en désaccord mais bon ça c'est
encore autre chose ça justifie que je
sois suspendu merci de reconnaî non mais
il y a aussi vous avez été dans un parti
politique il a un moment où normalement
c'est c'est cohérent rigoler mais
attendez les tr/4 des journalistes les
tr/art des journalistes de l'audiovisuel
du service public sont encarté sont
encarté à gauche àextrême gauche qui
leur en fait le GRI pouro
G parce que vous laissez pas parler les
gens c'est tout vous laissez pas parler
les genscou la parole on devraitire
pareci d' disent des satises excusez-moi
on lui met un tant de parole ce serait
pareil vous voulez voudriez quoi mais
parce qu' on devrait mettre un temps de
parole limité aussi ici parce que vous
parle si on le limite à la qualité du
propos le votre sera ridicule allez
là Gan calme-toi s mal qu'est-ce qui se
passe mais rien mais il y a pas de souci
je trouve que cette cagnotte est
ridicule non mais la question était pas
sur la cagnotte la question c'est sur
estce que tu comprends la décision de
l'arom c'est les deux voilà bon en vrai
ça pénalise Jean Messia mais ça pénalise
aussi les partis politiques parce que
pardon il y a peut-être des mouvements
qui n'ont pas envie que le temps de
parole de Jean Messia leur soit décomté
c'est ça qui est injuste c'est injuste
pour Jean Messia et c'est injuste pour
les partis
politiques qui qui êtes-vous pour dire
que que cette canote est ridicule il y a
quand même près de 3000 donateurs donc
vous êtes en train d'insulter 3000
personnes mais la première je la trouve
déjà ridicule donc la deè justement
c'est pas à vous dire ça le problème si
vous voulez je vais vous expliquer le
fin mot de l'histoire de ces cagnotes
c'est que on veut interdire aux Français
par tous les moyens de s'exprimer on on
le fait
à on fait on fait à la télé on fait en
conduisant des djihades judiciaires
contre ceux qui dis parlent différemment
du du système et en réalité les
qu'est-ce que montrent les cagnottes
chaque euro qui est donné dans les
cagnottes que j'ai lancé c'est une
graine tricolore versé par une France
qui veut rester tricolore et chaque euro
qui est donné dans la cagnotte c'est une
larme dans l'œil d'un gauchiste vous
allez me faire croire que c'est un
message que vous êtes en train de faire
passer à travers cet argent et pas vous
en mettre plein les poches non pas du
tout parce que
attendez j'ai quand même 10 procès à
affronter he je sais pas si vous si je
vous l'ai dit mais j'ai 10 procès sur le
Do donc vous avez des problèmes
financiers moi c'est vraiment une
question vous avez des problèmes
financiers par rapport au procès qui me
sont entés oui Mad plus travailler
si j'ai pas de revenu et que j'ai 10
procès où il y a payé entre 5 et 10000 €
par procès parce que les procédures
d'appel les incidentes et cetera comment
comment vous faites vous expliquez-moi
vous avez un modèle économique
pour question c'est pourquoi vous avez
10 procès les gens ils ont pas 10 procès
les gens qui n regardent pourquoi vous
avez eu 10 procès par que jeis alors je
vais répondre à ça si vous me permettez
j'ai dit procès parce que il y a la
façade de l'État de droit d'accord il y
a les façades les institutions de façade
reste le Conseil d'État le Conseil
constitutionnel l'arcom mais derrière
dans les coulisses ces institutions sont
en réalité verérolé par une idéologie et
par des idéologues qui veulent tout
simplement en finir avec la France quand
vous pensez que le président du Conseil
d'État d'accord a likquer pendant la
dernière présidentielle plusieurs tweets
ou transan antiémour c'est son rôle de
faire ça quand le CSA invite en tout cas
l'arcom invite le 29 mars une conférence
animée par une militante décoloniale
Farida kemilade pour ne pas la citer qui
est soi-disant enseignant ta science po
ou tu es enseigné le genre l'inclusivité
le racisme systémique c'est c'est à
l'arcom de faire ça non donc vous voyez
bien que derrière la façade il y a une
idéologie qui est à l'œeuvre pour pour
détruire tous ceux qui parlent différ
j'ai décroché j'ai sur ma pancarte j'ai
mis non parce que je dis c'est pas à
l'arcom de décider de la même manière
que quand il y il y a des gens de gauche
qui parent sur le service public ou
ailleurs on décompte pas leur temps donc
je vois pas pourquoi l'arcom déciderait
de décomter le temps de Jean Messia il
est pas encarté il est pas encarté voilà
donc c'est pareil si on décompte le
temps de Jean Messia c'est ce qu'on a
dit tout à l'heure à ce momentl on
décompte le temps de G on
décte dire ça non mais
temp mais on peut décomter aussi le
temps de d'autres chroniqueurs qu'on
voit sur france télé il y a plein de
gens sur france télé qui sont encarté de
gauche et on décontre le temps pourquoi
on décontterit le
temps décte immédiatement le temps
deolen royalolen Royal est une femme
politique éventuellement aujourd'hui pr
laifation rendez compte c'est royale
très bien mais là le problème c'est pas
les hommes politiques ou les femmes
politiques qui sont en carté mais si on
si l'arcom commence à rentrer dans ce
registre là ça veut dire que tous les
chroniqueurs mais aussi tous les
journalistes de l'instant où il
défendent une idée voilà et à partir de
quel critère et ça veut dire que là on
bascule on bascule dans un tout autre
chose
lui est du côté dir le
gendarme non mais d'abord contrairement
à ce que dit Raymond moi j'ai jamais ét
encarté nulle part d'accord je présente
que moi et mes idées j'ai jamais pris
une carte nulle part d'accord non mais
c'est clair ça Jean méia lui c'est une
vaste hypocrisie c'est le représentant
sur les plateaux télé d'Éric Zemour pour
lequel il
bationc faites monter la voulais si je
voulais mais attendez
uxisésent mê
parler sur ça répond sur ça j'aurais été
encarté c'est vous qui décidez que moi
je vous avez été le porte-parole d'é
Zemour alors mais on aoit on a le droit
de changer de vie à un moment vous avez
changé de vie mais pas d'idée en tout
cas vous êtes le droit d'avoir mes idées
ou pas vous êtes le propagandiste d'
Zemour donc moi je
suis dire un TR il excuse-moi moi cet
après-midi j'ai un peu bossé l'émission
j'ai été voir je demande les
commentaires sur la cagnotte énormément
de gens qui donnent 5 € 10 €
air majoré G qui dis que mer partip
pascoup par que vous parlez notre nom
personne nous représente et cetera et
vous portez notre voix vous défendez des
valeurs auquelles nous croyons encore et
ben donc ces gens n'ont pas le droit
d'avoir des gens qui parle pour
eux tu pas les voil il faut pas les
museler faut laisser parler mais c'est
une vaste
hypocrisie pas que c'est une hypocrisie
quand Julia
C sont invit
second-i second moi je vais vous donner
l'exemple l'exemple fatalel garido non
l'exemple fatal non mais de Don jeis te
donner l'exemple fatal il est il est il
est c'est fini la verd va encore mettre
son nez dans dans dans ses feues Louis
Boyard Roseline Bachelot c'est tout
terminé merci elle est pas décé elle est
pas décomté Roseline Bachelot Gill verdz
merci au revoir Gill verd une fois de
plus les par nvitation
j lesconomist l'extrême gauche qui sont
invités sur France téléision ILT J il
sont
jille
pasexpre pas de problème mais
il Jean Michel tu le défonceras après
mais laisse parler c'est mon Gilou quand
Mme propage est les idées d'Éric Zemour
pour lequel il
a ce moment quearom le sanctionne
évidment
ID j'ai pas été payé par bachel
qu'est-ce que vous
rontez é payé par
vezv oui ou non ét payé
par c'est les Gill tu vois bien que le
problème c'est pas la carte puisque
monsieur n'est plus encarté le problème
c'est de diffuser des idées donc tu peux
être sanonné parce que tu me propages
des idées qui sont contraires à celles
de Jean Messia donc au même titre que
Jean Messia tu propages des idées tu
dois être tu dois être s atts j'ai juste
une question à à te poser sur France
interre on on propage quelle idéologie
la droite j'en sais rien je suis pas
représent tu sa c'est de la mauvaise FO
France Inter et France inf France Inter
et France Info et France 2 ils sont de
quelle obédience globalement là là là
ils font ce qu'ils veulent après ils ont
le droit ils on droit Mo je condamne pas
ça encore une fois mais
même réond à la question répond mais
j'en sais rien peut-être qu'ils ont une
sensibilité de gauche
maisensibilité de gauche
ok plus la
sensibilitéite dis vous avez quelqu'un
qui a bossé pour le parti d'éc Zemour en
face de vous et vous êtes des naïf enfin
c'est l'état de
droit vous touchiez pas de l'argent du
ministère de la Défense non vous avez
jamais touché de l'argent j'éta
fonctionnaire mais j'ai arrêté ça
justement j'ai arrêté y a 2 ans DISP
jusqu y a 2 ans vous touchez beaucoup
d'argent vous avez rien mis de
côté êes êes vous êtes là tout leso avec
un cachet
combienè cot Mo je cré pas de cot vous
répondz jamais vousêtes payit pas de
cagot
j'ich c'est quoi C don de leç qu'est-ce
que vous avez fait de votre argent moi
aussi j'ai très bien gagné ma vie tou
pas mon po j'ai plus un centime et
voilà tu pas don des d'éparg tu ve
donner faut mettre à droite
à vis est tous les
so tout
ce accident dans la vie a des divorces a
des maladies
croyezo je permettre ver tu as dû
prendre énormément beaucoup plus
d'argent que Jean mess mais mais je
crois que tu es fou toi tu veux que je
m'oblige pas à donner ton donnerai pas
tu prends tu gages beaucoup plus que
Jean M le mais tu es fou mais arrête
mais quel mytho mais arrête mais tu es
fou quoi excuse-moi bien sûr je tu es
mon ami je te je sais mon frère voilà
mais je sais combi je lui donne et tu
peux dire que tu gagnes beaucoup plus
que Jean Messia
crois-moian c'est pas vous qui le payez
Jean ma ça a été le ministère de la
Défense non c'est
pas ça fait longtemps que c'est fini ça
je crois qu' ministère de la Défense il
était plus payé que toi ici mais je sais
pas je prends les couill Jes bouore dans
confiture arrête
demain attends attends tu sais quoi tu
sais quoi si c'est ça si c'est ça j'ai
envie de Demer si c'est ça si c'est ça
je fin comme
ça mais oh c'est bon ça va attendez on
va se retrouver dans un instant
Guillaume a envie de défoncer Gill
encore
encorezétique aujourd'hui